currently five of our squad are actually
employed directly in Tata to our coaches
are employed in Tata lot of our members
supporters are either Tata employees or
X star employees so the link is massive
you know on a Saturday afternoon if you
if you came here and went into our bar
on a Saturday afternoon pre pre or post
match and you talked to the supporters
then you know one there would be a link
to Tata somewhere whether it be direct
or a family member it runs right through
the town the town is the Steamworks the
Steamworks is a town it's it's just
linked absolutely in every thread so
these job losses affect absolutely
everybody not just amber Allen every
business every shop every part of the
community the ripple effect it's like a
pack of cards basically
it's it's beyond it's beyond
comprehension I'm 58 years of age and
I've grown up in this town and um it is
what it is Porto but is the steelworks
to steal as I get again I said iliyan
it's it's it's it's part of everyday
life in this in this town it's so
important to that it's a vital cog in
the town it's the heartbeat of the town
basically
the town would without it the town would
be it doesn't it try not to think about
it to be honest it's so important and
it's so important that the plant is
flourishing
you